Speaker 1: . This is really funny, as many
of you know, or maybe you don't.
And I'll tell you, Joe Biden is sort of doing
pretty OK as president.
There's no perfect president.
Every president, every president does lots
of things that people don't agree with that
I don't agree with.
OK, but in this hyperpolarized entire environment
that we have in the United States, Joe Biden's
approval is quite healthy.
It's much higher than Donald Trump's ever
was.
And Joe Biden already in these first few months
of his presidency has some important major
achievements, including the covid relief bill,
including an incredibly successful vaccine
rollout and some other things with my.
More planned Fox News and other right wing
media are completely out of ideas about what
to cover.
They tried fake scandals.
They tried ginning up a crisis at the border,
which sort of worked actually.
They tried attacking the relationship between
Joe and Jill Biden as fake and stage managed
for public perception.
And none of it is really sticking.
I mean, the border thing is sticking a little
bit, but a lot of this stuff is just not sticking.
And look at the pathetic things that they
tried last night alone.
Here is Tucker Carlson claiming that Joe Biden's
secretary of defense, Lloyd Austin, said that
the single greatest risk our soldiers face
is having to serve alongside Trump supporters.
But when you watch the clip of Lloyd Austin
that he plays, Lloyd Austin doesn't actually
say that it is a fake scandal.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: Existential, if you've got a cliche,
he will read it on television.
It was Lloyd Austin, of course.
Lloyd Austin is a former defense contractor.
Not surprisingly, he's a full time ideologue
as well.
Having Lloyd Austin at the Pentagon is like
handing control of the entire U.S. military
to the editorial page of The New York Times.
Here is Lloyd Austin explaining the single
scariest risk our soldiers face is the possibility
they might have to serve alongside Americans
who didn't vote for Joe Biden.
Speaker 3: And if confirmed, I will fight
hard to stamp out sexual assault into the
ranks of racist and extremist.
The job of the Department of Defense is to
keep America safe from our enemies, but we
can't do that if some of those enemies lie
within our own ranks
Speaker 2: is a joke and a mediocrity.
And, of course, he was confirmed by the Senate
as if he was impressive.
Speaker 1: But he's not so understand that,
Tucker says Lloyd Austin claimed the biggest
risk to our troops is serving alongside people
who didn't vote for Joe Biden.
He plays a clip.
And in the clip, Lloyd Austin says we've got
to get sexual assault out of the military.
We've got to get racists out of the military
and we've got to get extremists out of the
military.
Now, maybe Tucker Carlson knows that the racists
and the extremists and the sexual assault
are Trump supporters.
I don't know.
I'm not saying that.
But linguistically, I can't see any other
connection between what Tucker Carlson said
is in that clip and what Lloyd Austin actually
says.
Then Tucker Carlson uses the latest.
Bill Gates, Jeffrey Epstein revelations to
just wide openly pander to the Kuhnen people.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: So two days after Bill Gates told
us on Twitter that he was getting a divorce,
there is new information about his relationship
with Jeffrey Epstein.
You know, those conspiracy theorists say a
small group of really powerful people control
the world and have an interest in little kids,
just a conspiracy theory, but we will tell
you what we do know.
Speaker 1: That's just ahead.
Edgy stuff, right?
So just straight up pandering to Kuhnen there.
Maybe this helps his ratings.
Maybe he has a big Kuhnen contingent in his
audience.
I don't really know.
Then Sean Hannity brings in Donald Trump Jr.
for a segment on the Steele dossier from was
it 2016, 2017.
We're almost halfway through twenty, twenty
one.
And Hannity brings on the son of a former
president to talk about a five year old document.
A Fox host, Laura Ingraham, going with a narrative
about the Democratic Party being in chaos
and falling apart and being in disarray.
She had one headline called Things Are Clearly
Falling Apart for Democrats and then another,
which included right wing bomb thrower Dinesh
D'Souza as a guest, which was called, quote,
GOP views gain traction as Dems in disarray.
And of course, this is all completely fake.
It's all completely made up.
If the current administration is notable for
anything, it's that we are four months in
and there are just no scandals and things
are calm and uncontroversial.
Now, we can all say, well, Joe Biden didn't
handle stopping the deportations the way that
he promised and I would be right there with
you.
And Joe Biden hasn't done enough here.
He hasn't done enough there or I don't like
the deadline he set for when to get troops
out of Afghanistan.
He said it at September 11th.
He should have done it by May 1st like Donald.
These are all fair criticisms and things that
we can all talk about.
But there's really no disarray.
There's really no scandal.
There's really no chaos where four months
and Joe Biden has gotten some major things
done.
Most Americans are more or less happy with
it, and Americans are very happy with the
stimulus bill that was done.
Americans are very happy with Joe Biden's
handling of the pandemic.
And Americans are very happy with Joe Biden's
handling of the vaccine rollout.
Lastly, from Laura Ingram, another blockbuster
powerful story called, quote, The left doesn't
actually have an agenda.
And this one is particularly funny because
Joe Biden passed covid stimulus, rolled out
vaccines, has a jobs bill proposal, has an
infrastructure bill proposal, has made some
tweaks to gun safety.
Doesn't mean you have to like them or think
there are enough.
But he made some tweaks to gun safety.
And yet it is Republicans who for four years
and especially now, openly so, Mitch McConnell
said it, they are not about anything other
than stop Democrats from doing anything.
Under Barack Obama, the Republican agenda
was stop Obama from doing anything under Trump.
The agenda was undo anything we can that Barack
Obama did.
And under Joe Biden, the agenda is not really
an agenda.
It's prevent Joe Biden from doing anything.
It's a good critique, not having an agenda,
not being for anything.
If it were true, it happens to be true of
the Republican Party.
And I don't know if they can do this for the
next four years, like at some point, will
they have to come up with something more substantive
to slam Joe Biden about at some point?
I mean, most presidents have some scandals.
Obama was sort of out of the ordinary in the
sense that he didn't have any major scandal.
Will they come up with something substantive
or will they will something happen?
That is actually a fair critique of Joe Biden
that would fall under the umbrella of scandal
or disarray.
Let me know what you think.
But they seem committed.
To trying to stop Joe Biden from doing anything
and from claiming that Joe Biden is getting
nothing done and is embroiled in scandal,
when that's actually not the case that's going
on, let me know what you think.
Can they do this for four years without anything
substantive?